so um okay let this is now
i i want to be clear this is not my idea
doctors
are saying that based on donald trump's
behavior of the last 72 to 96 hours
he needs a psychiatric evaluation all
right and and so
we saw we're i mean you could go back
years
but for this episode we saw on sunday
donald trump
while contagious with coronavirus donald
trump
went on a corona ride around walter reed
hospital with secret service agents in a
hermetically sealed
secret service vehicle to wave to his
supporters
this started to raise some red flags
that you know if you've not been paying
attention the last four years
maybe trump is not well mentally maybe
trump is not well cognitively
then donald trump pulled a bizarre
stunt where he checked himself out of
walter reed medical center on monday
flew back to the white house walked up
the back steps or the front steps i
don't know which is the back or the
front of the white house
and defiantly removed his mask
in his orange glory and filmed a
completely propagandistic video the
likes of which we anticipate seeing out
of north
korea but not necessarily the united
states
even donald trump jr has now said
according to gabriel sherman in vanity
fair
monday that he thinks trump is manic and
that an intervention is needed well
leanna wen who is a cnn medical analyst
a doctor a visiting professor at george
washington university
said based on donald trump's behavior a
psychiatric evaluation
would be in order if trump were her
patient and left the hospital while
still
infected to go for a car ride she
would demand a psychiatric evaluation
tweeting quote
if trump were my patient in unstable
condition
with contagious illness and he suddenly
left the hospital to go for a car ride
that endangers himself and others i'd
call security to restrain him
then perform a psychiatric evaluation to
examine his decision making capacity
that's a doctor my friends this is not
normal behavior
the barrage of manic tweets monday
morning
tuesday night it all
basically seals the deal that donald
trump maybe
as desperately as he needs coronavirus
isolation
needs a psychiatric evaluation now of
course
we have to ask could this be related to
the dexamethasone the steroid on which
donald trump has been put
to treat coronavirus uh maybe yeah
i mean why would trump risk people's
lives just to wave to fans outside of
the hospital well maybe it is the
dexamethasone but maybe it's just trump
because he doesn't care
donald trump has weaponized narcissism
and has destroyed any semblance of
empathy over the last four years trump
even tried tweeting that had he
not done his corona ride around the
hospital
the media would have said he's wrong not
to do it
see if you can follow this trump tweeted
tweeted quote
it is reported that the media is upset
because i got into a secure vehicle to
say thank you
to the many fans and supporters who were
standing outside of the hospital for
many hours
and even days to pay their respect to
their president
if i didn't do it media would say rude
ridiculous there is no one in the media
who would have said if trump safely
stayed in the hospital
trump's really bad because he's not
driving around
right now with coronavirus it's
ridiculous secret service agents were
disturbed by
it a veteran secret service agent
expressed dismay
at the corona ride around walter reed
and
um did say that when you were around
trump it's difficult for people to say
no that if you
say no uh you you you suffer
uh that that it leads to even worse
outcomes it is actually scary where we
are as a country right now
because not only do we have a president
who's been incompetent all along
his decision-making capability to the
extent that it ever existed
is particularly gone and you know we can
speculate is it the steroids
is it the disastrous polling is it that
the white house is so highly infected
with coronavirus it could be all of
these things it could be a combination
okay
it doesn't really matter how do you
think he ended up in the hospital with
coronavirus he tried to make a mockery
of facts and science
and this is where we are right now
whether he's fit to serve as president
should not even be a debate at this
point in time and yet
60 million or more people are still
going to vote for him and he could
could could but hopefully won't he could
get
another four years it is an existential
threat
not only to the united states but to
humanity for this man to get another
four years
he is out of control it is completely
weaponized
you all know what to do i won't even say
it let's just go to the break
you it's it's four letters i'll tell you
that i'll tell you and we're 27 days
okay but but i'm not going to actually
say it
you know what to do i want to take a
second to tell you about one of our
sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell
and that's actually why i reached out to
them about being a sponsor i've tried
tons of different face masks this year
like many of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap and it
features a disposable
five layer particle filter made of
activated carbon they also have
disposable cloth masks which are really
comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol wipes no touch
infrared thermometers and all of their
prices are
very reasonable i also love snh masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping
is free on orders over 150 dollars you
can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save twenty percent on
everything in their store
when you use the coupon code david